KUSHAGRA SHRIVASTAVA: Hello,
my name is Kushagra
Shrivastava.
I'm a lead on our apps
and games marketing.
Today I'll be talking about how
you can keep your users
engaged and coming back.
Larry Page, our CEO, once quoted
"products should be
like toothbrush.
Users should use them at least
twice a day." Building great
product is the key.
But to ensure your users
love and use
the product is critical.
In a recent survey, we found
that 40% of the users only use
an app for a week.
Nobody wants to be an app or a
game which has hundreds of
thousands of installs but
very few active users.
To avoid this, you need to
be smart about marketing.
And marketing always starts
with the product.
In this talk, we have laid out
a few basic principles that
will help you keep your users
excited, engaged, and coming
back for more.
Here are the five rules to
help boost engagement.
Rule number one, let data
drive the decisions.
It is extremely important that
you look at all key events and
life cycle of your consumers to
understand what is working
and what is broken.
You only can fix stuff once
you know it is broken.
There are various tools
out there which
can help you do that.
Google Analytics
is one of them.
The Google Analytics engagement
report helps you
discover how visitors
use your app.
You can use this set of reports
to track a wide range
of information about your users,
including the total
number of screens per visit, the
order in which screens are
viewed, the number of technical
errors an app
crashes, how often they return
to the app, how long the
sessions were, how long
individual app elements take
to load, and specific content
actions which are unique to
your app, like social
interaction, clicking on an
ad, or recommendations.
Data informs your product
and marketing.
Once you have the right data,
you have actionable insights
to make improvements
and boost usage.
The second rule is educate
and immerse.
For most first-time users,
installing and opening an app
is like going on a blind date.
The first impression is the
most important thing.
Don't assume that users will
figure out how your app or
game works.
Visually explain it to them,
and help them get started.
Also, tell them how to get help
if they ever need it.
The most basic thing you can do
is to have a great welcome
screen and build from there,
leading to fun, interactive
tutorials, on-screen
instructions and more.
This is your chance
to get creative.
Test different messages.
Try new things.
Number three, understand
the learning curve.
Every user has a learning curve,
and understanding that
is critical.
At a macro level, it is
important that you talk to the
user at the right time.
For example, if you're a game
developer, don't tell users on
how to use a new power play
mode which they can only
unlock after 30 hours
of game play.
That said, casually telling them
that this is a power play
mode which they can unlock
is all right.
Fourth principle, remind why
users like your app.
An app is not the center of the
universe for most people.
Well, for some die-hard
fan, it might be.
That said, to keep users engaged
and coming back, you
have to remind them why they
love your app and what are
they missing out.
Some app developers have used
native Android features like
push notifications, widgets,
lock screen widgets, live
wallpapers, to boost engagement,
stickiness, and
constantly bring users
back to the app.
Pulse is a great example.
They leverage rich notifications
to push new
stories to the user on
the home screen.
Also, it is a great time for
you to remind yourself that
the objective is to keep users
engaged and not spam them.
These features can easily be
an overkill and frustrating
for the user.
Use them smartly.
The last principal that I'm
going to talk about is to
reward and bring your
users back.
Now that your product is doing
the marketing for you, you
need to look into the final
aspect of retention and
engagement which is custom
marketing and loyalty.
Put your existing marketing
channels like social media,
in-app reward mechanism, emails,
gamification, et
cetera, to use based on the
data you have seen.
Reward the power users
with something
tangible, unique and personal.
It will help boost their morale
to share your messages
and keep them active.
Overall, aim to boost the
lifetime value of your users.
At the end of the day, it is
all about building apps and
experiences which you yourself
would like to use.
And gradually start a
conversation with the user and
make the experience personal.
I hope this was useful, and
thank you for watching.